we're used to imagining Mars as a cold
Barren Planet devoid of any life-giving
water and atmosphere it's been covered
with lifeless deserts seared by lethal
Cosmic radiation for billions of years
now still surface of Mars Bears traces
of ancient seas and rivers which were
even more turbulent and water abundant
than those on earth and the deeper we
delve into the history of the red planet
the more startling aspect it assume
[Music]
Cosmo this is
Mars that's what it is believed to look
like several billion years ago
heat and liquid were trapped within the
dense CO2 atmosphere the planet was
shrouded
in numerous Rivers used to flow on its
surface and most of its northern
hemisphere used to be covered by
water however all this was to
vanish leaving behind early traces on
rocks it is thought that the weak and
unst able magnetic field of Mars failed
to protect it against solar
wind in hundreds of millions of years
that followed its atmosphere gradually
deteriorated with water vapor breaking
down into hydrogen and oxygen the
lighter gas rose up into the upper
layers of the atmosphere to float away
into
space as for oxygen it reacted with
rocks which gradually led to the planet
getting getting tarnished by rust and
sound a thin layer of orange dust and
perpetually frozen
ground that is all that remains of the
great abundance of water on the red
[Music]
planet to have a better understanding of
what is currently going on on Mars we
will first have to look in its
depths thanks to the sensitive graphs on
board the inside probe which have been
exploring the inner makeup of the
celestial body for four long years
scientists have some ideas about the
processes running in the planet's depths
at the very center of the planet we can
observe a large and massive core of iron
sulfur and
nickel its radius is more than half the
size of the entire Celestial body and
its temperature lies between 1,800 and
2,000 cin because of the enormous
pressure most of the core is in a solid
state and therefore incapable of
producing a stable magnetic
field the core of the planet in its turn
is surrounded by a layer of melt mantle
about 1,2 km thick its composition is
heterogeneous and depends on its depth
the lower layers contain various metal
oxides while the upper ones are composed
of Olivine and
iates on the outside the mantle is bound
by a massive crust the average depth of
which is estimated to be about 50 km
this is 5 to 10 times greater than the
parameters of our planet's Oceanic
lithosphere and comparable with the
thickness of the Earth's
continents it is also noteworthy that in
the northern hemisphere the Martian
crust consists predominantly of andesite
and in the southern hemisphere of Basalt
which may indicate that it was formed at
different
times Decades of observation have
yielded hundreds of thousands of images
of the surface of Mars by putting these
together scientists have been able to
produce an incredibly accurate and
detailed map of the celestial body
containing many objects some of them are
quite small While others stretch for
thousands of kilometers and can be seen
with telescope even from Earth and one
such region of interest is valis
marineris this gigantic system of
intertwining canyons and chasms
stretches along the planet's equator for
4,500
km its western part is deeply cut by the
immense volcanic thsis plateau and our
Plunge Into The Great drift will begin
almost in the center of the giant
Plateau it is here that the unique and
Myster ious region marked on maps as
nocus labyrinthus or the Labyrinth of
night is located it is an area of
chaotic terrain stretching
1,200 km from west to east here numerous
deep steep edged drifts intersect
multiple times dividing the surface of
the planet into regularly shaped blocks
the top is made up of softer lighter
sediment heavily eroded while the base
is made up of solid Bedrock over
billions of years the slopes of the
chasms have collapsed in many places
leaving behind numerous
landslides it is thought that it was
here that precipitation that fell on the
surface of the Upland regions in ancient
times accumulated together and flowed
eastwards in Unstoppable turbulent
streams evidence of this can be seen in
the traces of deep water erosion seen at
the bottom of most chasms and in the
layered structure of slopes and
landslides in addition spectral analysis
shows that certain minerals that require
liquid water to form such as hematite
Opals and Dion sulfates for example are
abundant in this region observations
show that noctis labyrinthus is
periodically obscured by dense fog
meaning that it is still one of the most
humid regions on the
planet it is thought that the water
contained in the soil evaporates into
the thin Martian atmosphere during the
day and the high walls of the Gorges
prevent the humid air from
dissipating with temperature dropping
the water condenses as microscopic ice
crystals that slowly settle on the
surface forming a thin layer of
frost as one moves Eastward the bizarre
interlocking chasms of nocus labyrinthus
gradually morph into a system of giant
Canon ions that occasionally intersect
over billions of years powerful streams
of water dug deep channels in the Maran
rocks and then winds and sandstorms ate
away at their slopes But whichever path
we take it will eventually lead us to
the giant Coates
gasma it is here that the deepest point
of the valis marinaris is recorded it
lies 11 km below the surrounding
plateaus calculations show that in
ancient times copri gasma was a narrow
and long running water lake which when
it is fullest was comparable in volume
to the Earth's Black
Sea the region is believed to be one of
the most promising objects for future
research the soil of the bottom may
contain traces of ancient
microorganisms and its slopes are quite
literally recorded pages of the
geological history of the planet and are
of great scientific value as we continue
along the canyon we find that it
gradually loses its steepness and gently
dissolves into the giant crisy
plena here too however we see traces of
the water element in the form of rounded
Terraces and elongated Islands probably
formed by sediment from valis
marinaris similar geological formations
can be found in our planet in the Deltas
of major rivers such as the Amazon and
the Nile
thus we have made acquaintance of one of
the most tremendous and visible
evidences of there having been water in
the ancient eras of Martian
history however the giant valis
marinaris Rift has only been explored
from space the wheels of Mars Rover have
never touched it to get a closer look at
the red planet we will have to travel
far to the
east after flying several thousand kilom
over on friendly ly Rocky deserts we
finally reach a large crater called
Gale about 3.8 billion years ago a
massive asteroid collapsed here leaving
a deep circular depression 154 km across
at its Center there is Mount sharp a
vast irregular Upland area composed of
layers of
sediment in ancient times there may have
been a large circular lake with a
central island in the present day
however Gail crater is known as the
landing area for the Curiosity Rover the
story of this Mission began almost 11
years ago when the Curiosity autonomous
probe landed on the surface of Mars on
the 6th of August 2012 a symbol of human
determination and thirst for knowledge
the mission's goals included studying
the planet's climate and relief as well
as searching for water and traces of
biological
life
almost immediately after landing the
Rover found evidence that the planet
used to be much wetter in the past than
it is now the first photos transmitted
to Earth clearly show a valley washed
away by a torrent of water the area has
been dubbed peace valleys meaning The
Valley Of Peace and is one of the
clearest instances of evidence of water
erosion on the planet curiosity then
headed east and soon reached a sand pit
called Rock Nest here it took its first
soil sample and found it contained
around 3% of water next the Rover turned
Southwest and continued on its
way it crossed the rocky wastelands of
the Glenelg region where ruthless winds
had crushed sediment down to bedrock
formed more than four billion years ago
then climbing occasionally up Rocky
slopes curiosity reached the Western end
of the bagal dunes studying the
sedimentary rocks which are relatively
recent in geological
terms from the desert the Rover turned
South and set out on a long and tiring
climb up the slope of a small mountain
range called Vera
Rubin along the way the sand and silica
and its Wheels gave way to hematite an
ion oxide that only forms when in
contact with liquid water water it turns
out that the mountain range is largely
made up of this substance which means
that in earlier times the climate in
this region was much more humid in total
curiosity stayed on Mars for more than
3,000 days roughly five times the
planned duration of its
Mission despite all the difficulties and
obstacles it traveled nearly 30 km
across a harsh Martian terrain and took
28 samples of alien soil the probe's
chemical analyzes detected not only
water but also organic molecules
including Benzene and aromatic
hydrocarbons while its cameras beamed
back to us thousands of photos and
videos leaving the tenacious Mars Rover
behind we will continue our journey and
head
Southwest here hel's plena is one of
thear largest impact craters on Mars it
is thought that about 4 billion years
ago a massive asteroid with a radius of
about 50 km crashed into the planet here
at high speed the terrific explosion
left behind a gigantic crater about
2,300 km in size and millions of tons of
rock were crushed and ejected far beyond
its
limits some of these fragments may have
reached out of space and then crashed to
the planet's surface hundreds or
thousands of kilometers away from the
site of the cataclysm it should be noted
that at that time Mars was likely to
have been a friendlier and more
favorable Celestial body than it is now
the giant lowland area that appeared at
the impact site was quickly filled with
water forming a large lake or a
drainless Inland
Sea over billions of years it gradually
shallowed and became what we see today a
huge crater more than 7 km deep from a
distance the bottom of the Basin may
look smooth and flat but this is just an
illusion in fact it is covered with
numerous small hills and fractures whose
appearance is largely accounted for by
the movement of layers of subterranean
ice similar relief occurs on Earth in
Arctic Baron expanses and permafrost
zones due to its great depth the
atmospheric pressure in this region is
about twice as high as the global
average resulting in unusual weather
phenomena for instance from time to time
a misty Haze forms over the crater which
is uncharacteristic of
Mars the wind carries some of the Mist
out of the crater but its wisps quickly
disperse in the thin atmosphere or
settle on the Frozen
rocks during marshan winter the hell is
PL IA is entirely covered with frost and
when seen from the earth appears as a
large bright spot because of this the
area has long been mistakenly considered
an Upland and it wasn't until the end of
last century that its true nature was
determined next our route takes us to
the north to jezero Crater which used to
be a large running water lake in the
past the SAA River flowed into it from
the north North and the Neta River from
the West traces of these large water
arteries are still to be seen on the
surface of
Mars these appear as layered deposits of
Fluor sediment and large scal marks on
the mountainous walls it was one of
these regions that became the priority
Target of the perseverance Rover which
descended into jezo crater on the 18th
of February
2021 originally the Rover was planned to
land near the Three Forks area in the
nareta river valley however weather
conditions shifted The Landing Point 1.7
km to the southeast and the Rover was
separated from its Target by an area of
impossible sound called
SATA it was at this point that the
unique Ingenuity helicopter got to show
its worth it flew over the surface of
the planet and provided a wide angle
Panorama of the ancient Delta as well as
a unique photo of the Cod zodiac Plateau
2.3 km from the Rover's Landing Point
once the Rover had settled in and
reconed its surroundings it started out
on a long arduous Journey around the
unfriendly desert that separated it from
its destination traveling south along
the very edge of SATA the Rover stopped
from time to time to collect soil
samples at the same time Ingenuity
successfully completed flight after
flight beaming back to us many photos of
Mars from previously inaccessible
angles on Mars day 168 the spacecraft
turned Westward the idea was to pass
along the bottom of the crater skirt the
southern tip of SATA and reach a Rocky
Ridge along which it would head north
towards the
Delta however the terrain proved
difficult and the Rover was forced to
turn back pretty much retracing its way
back to the landing area perseverance
set off towards its
destination after smoothly skirting the
northern part of the desert it gradually
turned
westwards eventually after a long and
dous journey the Rover did reach the
Delta and began exploring it this
occurred in April
413 Martian days after it had
landed by now perseverance has traveled
more than 18 km across the unfriendly
Martian desert it has collected 15 soil
samples and sent more than 166,000
images as well as gigabytes of data from
various
senses in addition The Moxy vehicle
which is part of the Rover's science
payload successfully obtained about 100
G of oxygen from the Martian
atmosphere's carbon dioxide which seems
to reveal prospects for future
colonization of the planet at the same
time perseverance seismographs recorded
several Mars Quakes enabling scientists
to learn more about the internal
structure of the celestial body the
Ingenuity helicopter proved just as
useful it has completed more than 50
flights by now traveling a total of over
8 kilm thus convincingly proving that
even in the rarified atmosphere of Mars
it is possible to use aircraft for
research and
exploration
in addition to Desert Landscapes and
Rocky debris perseverance occasionally
photographs the night sky of Mars for
example this little white dot here is
one of its satellites day
Mar more recently perseverance captured
fur boss briefly eclipsing the sun this
unique observation was not just a
spectacular sight but it also provided
astronomers with a wealth of important
data
unlike our planet Mars has two
satellites which are very small
irregularly shaped celestial
bodies observations and spectral
analysis suggest that Phobos and damos
are similar in composition to carbonous
asteroids but their exact Origins are
still a subject of scientific
debate one hypothesis claims that they
are the remnants of a small Celestial
body captured by Mars from the main
asteroid belt several billion years ago
the tidal forces of the planet probably
tore the object into many fragments and
fobos and damos are the largest to them
all according to another hypothesis a
large protoplanet allegedly collided
with young Mars at the dawn of the solar
systems
formation as a result of this cataclysm
some of the fragments were thrown into
space where gravitation shaped them into
two rather large objects fobos is the
larger of the satellites it orbits the
planet above the equator at an altitude
of about 6,000 km which is about 64
times less than the distance from the
Moon to the Earth incidentally some
man-made satellites above our Earth
Drift 3 to five times higher than this
Celestial body however Phobos is so
modest in size that when observed from
the surface of Mars it appears three
times smaller than our moonone us even
at this distance another surprising fact
is that furbos has an extremely low
average density approximately 1.9 G per
cubic
cm this means that up to 40% of its
volume must be Hollow it is possible
that this object like some asteroids in
our system consists of several pieces of
debris held together by gravity
alone due to Tidal forces Phobos is
gradually losing height about 1.8 m per
Century it is estimated that in 10 11
million years it will be crushed by the
pool of Mars into many fragments and
that after another 33 million years they
will finally collapse onto the surface
of the red planet by that time Mars will
be likely to lose its second satellite
deos currently this Celestial body is
moving in a circular orbit with a r
radius of about 232,000
km but this distance is gradually
increasing calculations show that in a
few million years the satellite will
finally leave the gravitational
influence of Mars and float in space
quite
independently deos is a very dark object
because its surface absorbs almost 93%
of the light shed on it the satellite
small size means that it disc cannot be
seen from Mars with a naked eye damos
appears to The Observer as a pinpoint
source of light even though quite
bright its orbit makes it appear to
drift across the marshan sky towards
Phobos but this is just an illusion in
fact both satellites orbit Mars in the
same
direction when you look at Mars Frozen
in its immutability it is hard to
believe that once upon a time turbulent
Rivers would run across its surface
their Force by far greater than that of
rivers on Earth the expanses of the red
planet are full of riddles and surprises
and most of them remain to be uncovered
yet and although it may appear that Mars
has long been in its Autumn years by now
human tenacity and thirst for knowledge
May Supply another page in its history
yet every everyone has a chance to
contribute to this process by
participating in space exploration or
just liking this video it is thanks to
this little action that millions of
people will get a chance to notice and
check out this video and who knows some
of them might even help reveal new
limits of the universe let's keep in
[Music]
touch